I want to think about binomials this is
a binomial right by the oh just means
it's got two terms in there and it's
raised to a power of some kind okay so
this is often also called binomial
expansions but it includes more stuff
than just expanding stuff that's why
it's the theorem okay it includes things
like this okay so let's have a look at
the basic expansions this is um we're
moving past the properties of Pascal's
triangle now basic expansions okay
let's think about as a classic example
let's take it by the new expansion with
an index of zero okay we'll start with
zero because there is a good place to
start in Pascal's triangle starts there
- okay if I take a binomial a simple one
like say 1 plus X ok I raise it to the
power of 0
what City it's just equal to 1 because
anything to the power of 0 is equal to 1
you could even argue there are good
reasons why you cannot get 0 to the
power 0 is 1 they go ok index 1 ok this
is not too hard because the numbers are
still smell excellent 1 1 plus X ok now
keep going how far do we need to go I'm
gonna go down to 3 and let's go to 4 I
think ok now actually I'm gonna need
some working out in space so let's do 2
1 plus X or squared now you know how to
do quadratics because we've been doing
them for a long time so you could
probably with no working out
tell me what the result is right it's 1
plus 2 X plus x squared X right next
index
now when you're cubing numbers we've
done do them so often and we don't
usually have to extend them so often
even okay but let's do it let's give it
going I can see that as one plus X times
one plus X or squared which is this
right so I'm just going to include that
expansion then it's at all right so now
we'll do one of them which is this and
then I'm gonna do X of them which is
this okay well I get there's still just
the one at the front there's only ever
that one constant right how many X's do
I have I have two here and I have one
there
what about you plus signs that's funny
so I'm going to get three X there right
how many X Squared's three again how
many X cubes one okay when we were doing
the sums of all these coefficients we
got to like key up and then we said okay
fine I can see a pattern here right so
can we do the pattern what would you
guess if we raise it to the power of
four do we have to do the working look
at your Pascal's triangle carefully I've
got my here you've got the yours there
in front of you okay
I'm predicting that I'm gonna start with
one every time from this stopping would
okay now I'm I'm writing it you can see
the way I've written is because my ones
first of my X's second I'm riding with
the powers of X ascending right sir my
first power of X is just 1 how many X's
^ what am I gonna
I predict for how many X Squared's six
how many X cubes back down to four how
many X to the four is just okay let's do
one more just for the sake of writing it
out can you see by the way you know how
I said to you you're gonna need to
memorize this number of rows and you
form wha
memorizing number of rows that's crazy
well wouldn't you start writing this a
few hundred times it starts to get in
there okay so I'm not expecting to
you're gonna have to stand in front of
mirror and recite these to yourself I
think after doing the work you'll get it
okay so what are you guessing how many
X's I'm guessing 5 min 10 and then 10
again and then back down to 5 and back
down to 1 okay all right now here is my
question okay you've done some basic
algebra you've seen a pattern okay
you're guessing that it's the case and
it's a good guess now my question is why
why why are these numbers right this one
this one why are they the numbers that
we just saw that was not gonna ask you
explain but does anyone have any ideas
in their head right now of why on earth
this would actually happen anyone I'm
not gonna ask you to do it I'm just
curious to see if anyone's there
mentally hmm
okay yeah do you think I'm ready yes it
is kind of kind of what probability is
about how do you how do you work out the
probability of nothing you say you've
got a fraction that you you've got
favorable outcomes over total outcomes
so there's always fractions involved
there are no fractions here but the same
numbers are important
those favorite out comes total outcomes
okay so kind of yes that's a good guess
I did give you a bit of a clue before it
we've actually not helped ourselves here
the reason why this doesn't look as
obvious as it is is because we have done
a lot of shortcuts
okay so underneath this I want you to
rule this off and we're going to do this
again but we're going to write it in I
hope a more helpful way okay a way that
will make the pattern why this gives you
these makes it more obvious okay so I am
rapidly okay this is the line I've got
to start with okay you gave it to me
straight off okay because you know that
result because you've done it for so
long
you blew it for years okay but where
does it come from okay this is um this
is back to you next to Row 2
when you say 1 plus X a square
what does it actually equal to like what
does the square mean it means multiply
again just this okay now when you first
learned about brackets and how to expand
them right
what should work was you might have
looked for given the foil you go first
outside inside last and you have to do
all of the matching up right you got to
do it's kind of like two people saying
hello to coming into a house with two
other people right the first guy says
hello to these guys right and then the
second guy says because you know he
doesn't wanna be a jerk either he says
hello to these two guys and then you end
up with those four terms right now you'd
have learnt that some of those four
terms can be combined and that's why we
didn't end up with
terms we ended up with three okay but
there really are four terms they're
interacting with each other let me show
you okay write this with me okay the
first one the green ones
that's one lot of oneplus X right and
then you've got X loss of 1 plus X okay
now these four terms why is it that they
collapse into three what it all depends
on how you write it
okay I think from here write these two
terms crazy
um these two terms one sorry
that's red okay they've become well this
one becomes a winner plot then the next
these guys become an X and x squared
four terms and now you can kind of see
why photos become three because these
are they're like terms that's why we
collect them like this okay huh but can
you see what's happening can you see
Pascal's triangle in here right it's a 1
and a 1 right gives you this number in
yeah right
that's in here and then you've got these
two guys off on the edges they've got no
one to add to right I've got no one in
common over there
and so I just end up with a 1 and an x
squared what is can I say that again
maybe I wasn't clear
okay this one he's like I want to add to
someone but I've got no one they're just
like this guy right he looks around and
all he's got is that that's why you and
they get one of you right this guy is
like well I've got to to add from right
it literally comes from these two and
that's why it turns into 2x this guy
does the same thing as before
can you see what happen if we do it one
more time let's do it for an X 3 this is
gonna be messy for me because I've run
out of space I'm gonna rub off a few
things
not that kind of missing sorry I'll do
it right underneath where I hide before
okay cuz I'm almost there
okay let's do this expansion and see if
we can see what's going on in here okay
so sorry 1 plus X okay how will I write
it in such a way like I did here to make
the pattern obvious well I think it's 1
plus x squared you're happy with that
one but I know that just like he are
okay this is this is three terms like
this right that line again but now
instead of going straight to here right
I'm gonna write it out in a way that
shows this kind of relationship okay so
go to write it like this one x squared
that's the first expansion of this and
then I'm gonna write this guy Thanks 2x
squared plus X cubed can you see it can
you see it
look at the different parts the one
right this guy here looking at this row
this one he looks for things to add up
into right and there's only one that one
empties so it ends up with just one the
X's they look around for who dad up to
okay there's a 1 and a 2 1 and a 2 these
guys right that's why you get 3
okay the X Squared's do the same thing
and just like from before there was a
two-to-one that's where this expansion
came from right and so that's why you
end up with 3x squared and of course
that X cubed off on the end he is lonely
just like the one is okay and the
pattern continues from there so now when
you have a look at these guys and if you
make the powers really crazy well you
can make the powers up to ten off of
your diagram right and you can just read
off the coefficients because you know
they've followed this pattern you've
done all the work to construct it when
you constructed the triangle okay and so
you can quote these results you don't
need to do any of this monkeying around
just like you don't need to do any of
this marking around you can go straight
there because you know this result we
matter you've established the connection
between this and all of this now you
know all of these results as well does
that make sense
cool